oh
what the hell is going on over here
oh frank's trying to kill himself oh my
god is he all right frank are you all
right
don't try to stop me oh my god oh so
he's alive lost all my money in a ponzi
scheme charlie i'm broke his neck is so
thick i feel like he's just going to
swing and dangle around for a reason
that's what it is that's what it is
it's not going to work for you your next
two things care to me tie a chair to me
time's tough huh
[Music]
very nice performance very nice and
clean performance welcome welcome to our
legitimate
show of kids uh very very very nice
which one of these talented uh
entertainers who i am not attracted to
at all will be the winner i'm not
attracted to any of them none of them
and that's the way it is anyway
everybody put your hands together and
clap for the kids clap clap and you wave
goodbye wait wave goodbye go to your
dressing rooms we're gonna start the
show go on it's okay just don't touch go
to there going to their dressing room
over there on that side of the stage i
am going to my dressing room we will be
right back i'm over
[Music]
he came at the here time
is he sleeping yes
he's sleeping right over there
just the way you like him
[Music]
did you bring the toll
confound your lousy toll trolls
god damn it stop laughing at me
you gotta pay the troll toll if you want
to get into that voice hole you gotta
pay the troll toll to get in
you want the baby boys hole you gotta
pay the troll toe you gotta pay the
troll dog to get in
troll toe
what you say
hey
[Music]
with us today is frank reynolds local
business owner and a man with a
harrowing story that's right
a few days ago
three thugs try to mug me i want to be
very clear about something um
these pieces of garbage they don't know
who the hell they're dealing with
do you think maybe you could eat that
sandwich later i'm starving yeah nothing
to eat in this show let's get back
so these punks yes i don't know if they
wanted money or they wanted something
more sexual but it's a lucky thing i had
my pieces
your pieces my gun oh anyway i started
blasting
wow i don't see so good so i missed then
they ran away i ran after him okay bang
try to shoot him in the back but i don't
want so good either anyway
you guys all think i'm a hero and i'll
accept that responsibility
hello
ongo gablogian the art collector charmed
i'm sure
i'm going to invite you to a show okay
but first
allow me to destroy your gallery
derivative
[Music]
that
i love i absolutely
love
um that's just the air conditioner i
want it
it's everything i mean look at us we're
just air conditioners i mean after all
we're just walking around on the planet
breathing conditioning the air
i condition it hot that conditions it's
cold i mean it's symbiotic no no i mean
we're just the air conditioners walking
around on this planet screwing each
other's brains out
[Music]
all right frank here's another idea
oh where'd you come from i've been
walking next to you the entire time i'm
sorry i'm a little uh lit
and uh i've been going over this
thing i'm trying to figure out how to
bang donna i know you've been talking
about it for the last five miles
you know what dude it doesn't matter i
got a better idea i think you should
bang gail the snail
[Music]
dude what's more depraved than that huh
plus you're not blood-related so it's
not that weird
that is a good idea i like the way
you're thinking
what's in it for you huh
what's in it for you don't worry about
what's in it for me dude
oh my god you are disgusting
a disgusting animal
[Applause]
we gotta definitely write a song about
how we do not diddle kids do not little
kids it's no good diddling kids there is
no quicker way for people to think that
you are diddling kids than by writing a
song about it you gotta write songs and
say oh i wouldn't do it with anybody
younger than my daughter or no little
kids gotta be big older than my wife
from my daughter or something like that
[Music]
i uh want to invite you to a wrestling
match
oh and uh
guys we all chipped in to get you these
uh
uh this is a coming-home present
[Music]
and thank you for your service
[Applause]
[Music]
hey kid what's happening oh what is it
sorry sir the darn thing won't print you
mind if i take a look-see oh no it's
okay yeah um
i i think it's a paper jam
there's the culprit thanks mr woodhouse
damn it was in the tray three that you
didn't check
it just was hiding back there it was
like a little piece of paper
let me well let me ask you a question
did i just do your job for you
excuse me did i did i just do your job
for it
i guess so you're fired get the hell out
of here go on pack your up and get
out of here
if we're gonna turn this company around
we gotta start cutting the crust off
this sandwich you hear that yeah
okay well we're on the schuylkill river
and uh it's home to many uh weird
fish-like creatures and also the
depository of uh all of the unsolved
crimes and murders in philadelphia
and charlie and i we go down to sewer
and first thing we do is we preserve our
clothes we take take our clothes off we
get totally naked because you don't want
to get wet we ball our clothes up we
stick them up someplace high there's
this waitress who charlie's in love with
and uh
i banged her charlie got really upset
when i banged the waitress uh but it was
a lot of fun she was a nice piece of ass
we don't know who you're talking about
charlie he's my buddy we sleep together
we hang out together once i pooped him
to bed i blamed it on him
one time the guys got hooked on crack it
was really crazy well they found a baby
in a dumpster they wanted to make some
money with the baby but nobody would buy
the baby because it was white they sort
of had to turn it brown we were fighting
over the sword and just about when we
were about to hit each other with the
sword social services came in we thought
we were killing the baby
i don't understand this talk charlie
wrote this musical
oh man it was really funny i played a
troll on the musical oh yeah and it's
called the night man cometh
i can sing my song if you like
you gotta you gotta pay the troll toll
to get into this boy's hole
yeah
i'm telling you yeah
i was saying uh soul he was saying i he
thought i was saying boys whole one of
the things i like doing most is banging
i uh
i go out and bang a lot of
okay good i'm here
oh what on earth did you do to your face
i had it done at a funeral home why why
why where the hell am i gonna go to the
goddamn makeup counter at macy's you go
to a funeral home to get gruesome
repairs look
you look like you're at your own wake
frank
i
need some water
my mouth is dry
your mouth is dry go into the toilet and
run your mouth under the sink
okay yeah can i could i yeah can i i had
us
who's that he's the mortician i invited
him oh you brought the mortician okay
well that's not gonna seem strange to
anybody at all i figure he's a
why would i have a like that near
me if i had something to hide um
associating with a man like that's not
gonna make you look any better now frank
if i'm correct when you were a boy you
were admitted into a
mental institution is this correct
that's correct
but soon after it was discovered that i
wasn't mentally disabled so they let me
go and
they let me go with the proper paperwork
clearing me of everything i would like
to add into evidence article one uh mac
will you please read this document
by the power of the commonwealth of
pennsylvania read mental institution
hereby decrees frank reynolds do not
have
donkey brains
what that is an official document what
is that brain on it well it's written
right here in plain english frank would
you like to clear this up for everybody
well
all the kids in the neighborhood knew i
got sent upstate
so they started calling me frankie
donkey brains and it was very traumatic
oh so i got my mommy to drive me back up
to the looney bin where they signed this
official certificate exonerating me of
all donkey brains
okay um
let's talk about i ain't talking about
nothing
this skull is fort knox why don't you
trust therapists
i opened up to a therapist just once
i was a kid
i got into a fight
the doctor asked me question after
question
got me so scrambled up
next thing you know
i was shanghaied upstate to a nip with
school you know what a nitwit school is
i assume you mean a school for the
mentally disabled
yeah
not just for nuts in the head
bodies too
back then science was real crude they
stuck us all together
my roommate was a frog kid
you ever see a frog kid a frog kid
yeah
the place was windowless
there was a guard every 10 feet
all the rooms had drains in the floors
so they could hose us down how terrible
got my first kiss there
[Music]
frank
it was terrible
[Music]
but not her
she was an angel
always smiling
that's because she had no lips
but her mouth was still very much in
play
let's talk about the dishes oh
she died two weeks later
she thought she was a spaceman with a
plastic bag for a helmet oh
oh
oh you unzipped me
it's all coming back
it's all coming back i hate you
it's all coming back you understand i
don't like it i don't like to think
about it
[Music]
this is
with a plastic bag for a helmet oh
oh you unzip me out
[Music]
oh happening
come on come on